diese leute das muss man sich mal auf
der zunge zergehen das niederrhein
konditorei kuppenheim und wiese wo gibt
es noch qualität wie diese und jetzt den
orangen kuchen auf der wiese
[Musik]
du hast gedacht und jetzt willkommen bei
einem neuen video leute ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut mir fällt auf
ich sehe heute sehr rathaus mit diesem
kragen hier fast zu brav für mich na ja
egal leute heute mit einem video dass
wir irgendwann mal einen gefallen ist
als ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
gucke auch nicht mal viel fernsehen
allerdings hin und wieder schon und zu
fernsehen gehört ja auch werbung dazu
wie zu youtube natürlich auch wenn das
manche leute aus dem fernsehen
vielleicht nicht so einsehen
gut auf jeden fall habe ich mir gedacht
setzt du dich mal in den kukksi ein
bisschen tv werbung an und fest ist
einfach mal produkte aus der tv werbung
an ihr könnt euch wirklich nicht
vorstellen was das für eine arbeit war
ja währung ist ja sowieso ätzend ich
sage heute morgen bestimmt zu zwei
stunden vorm fernseher und habe dann
immer eingeschaltet waren wieder werbung
geben weil es dauert ganz schön lange
bis man mal vernünftige werbung findet
mit irgendwelchen sachen die man im
supermarkt kaufen kann gut es hat
funktioniert ich war gerade einkaufen
und ich glaube wir haben insgesamt acht
sachen die gerade aktiv in der
fernsehwerbung laufen
die würde ich jetzt mal zusammen mit
euch testen wenn ihr sagt hey die
formale der finden wir cool dann geben
wir auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal einen
dicken noch nach oben für noch einen
zweiten part
dann will ich gar nicht lange lagern und
wir starten sofort mal mit werbung nur
eins ich frage mich immer fertig so eine
werbung aus bringt weil das wird zwei
flaschen miteinander sprechen
das habe ich schon so oft gesehen so
leute als erstes habe ich ja ich glaube
dass kennen auch die meisten von euch
wir haben hier so ein bio bio bio bio
bio
ich weiß nicht ob wir noch irgendwie
drin ist was zumindest in der werbung so
ich probiere es einfach mal schnell
nicht auf jeden fall sehr sauer muss ich
leider ganz ehrlich sagen ist gar nicht
meins aber vielleicht schmeckt euch
keine ahnung also das war das erste
produkt ich muss auch sagen ich habe
wirklich relativ viel geld dafür
ausgeben ich glaube insgesamt über 20
euro alleine dieses shampoo was gar
nicht für mich ist da steht drauf ab 40
aber ich habe jetzt trotzdem mitgenommen
kostet 7 euro gut wie mach weiter
mit dieser werbung wo also da muss ich
sagen das ist jetzt das erste was ich
gar nicht mal so schlecht finde probiere
ich mal die haben wir die beiden sachen
auch schon einmal tic tac kam und noch
martina also dann einmal tick tack tick
tack classic play cool ich hoffe das
waren jetzt auch die richtig aus der
werbung aber ich glaube schon
wir probieren einfach mal krieg tick
tack tick tock jetzt habe ich da gerade
etwas durcheinander gebracht ich dachte
nämlich die heißen auch tik tok somebody
heißen ab tecdax wegen diesen neuen
verstörenden musical
das heißt ja auch so also zack sehr süß
schmeckt süß oder für spiel und
dokumentarfilme challenge in mach jetzt
den größten kaugummi der l
also finde ich eigentlich echt cool
daraus jetzt lockt auges zu machen
die werbung fand ich auch ganz okay und
wir machen jetzt weiter mit der nächsten
werbung und wer kennt es nicht
bitteschön quatsch oder was also wir
haben hier eine müller milch mit
proteinen geschmack was will ich werden
wir gleich sehen wir haben schon ganz
vorne im supermarkt die müller
milchprotein 26 gramm pro flasche so was
mache ich eigentlich gar nicht so keine
ahnung wir haben jetzt hier die neue
variante mit proteinen drin 26 gramm pro
flasche ja auf jeden fall nicht schlecht
so bevor wir hier weiter dummes zeug
lama probleme einmal ja echt lecker aber
dann merkte gesund ist das glaube ich
nicht deswegen stellen wir das direkt
zur seite na ja auch dass wir so ein
besonderer weise auch nicht willkommen
zur nächsten werden und zwar ist es
diese hier die habe ich bestimmt schon
100.000 mal gesehen
vitalis kraftfutter der neue mäßig snack
von dr
ich bin wirklich sehr gespannt wir haben
hier vitalis kraftsport mit protein das
ist normalerweise stellt man sich unter
minister so ein bisschen was süßes vor
aber hier einfach sauer queen drauf sind
wirklich gespannt ich mach das mal
schnell auf aber so richtig gar nicht so
sieht's aus und relation muss ich leider
auch sagen ich möchte mir überhaupt
nicht diese konsistenz davon und dann
der geschmack das passt irgendwie gar
nichts zusammen
ja also kann ich nicht empfehlen
trotzdem finde ich die werbung
eigentlich ganz cool ich meinen sie ist
voll cool aus und bringt es auf den
punkt aber gut ist halt nicht mein fall
machen weiter und zwar dieses zeug war
auch echt teuer vier euro also das muss
eigentlich wirklich gut schmecken
ich habe keine ahnung ich glaube in der
werbung habe ich irgendwas von marzipan
gehört es gab aber nur baumkuchen
spitzen ich mach das mal aus so sieht's
aus buch und finde ich auch wirklich
echt lecker vor anderen weihnachten ja
war dann mal hier
wie schmeckt eigentlich echt ganz gut
wenn man das jetzt mal so hoch rechnet
das hat vier euro kostet 123456
insgesamt zwölf drin
das heißt pro stück sondern kleines
stück hier umgerechnet 35 cent oder so
also günstig ist auf jeden fall was
anderes
[Musik]
oder freitags das freibad eröffnet die
zu unserer cafeteria fein und sahnig
blechkuchen einfach für das 40 münchen
sind die drei coppenrath wiese
nun gibt es doch qualität diese und
jetzt in der tiefkühltruhe leute das
muss man sich mal auf der zunge zergehen
lassen niederrhein konditorei kuppenheim
und wiese wo gibt es noch qualität wie
diese und jetzt den orangen kuchen auf
der wiese oder wie war das noch mal so
so muss marketing aussehen und nicht
anders ja dieser reim den kuchen muss
dann einfach kaufen leute ein habe ich
noch man muss auch sagen alles was ich
gekauft habe ist brutal ungesund aber
jetzt bin ich wirklich mal gespannt von
diesem fertigkuchen den habe ich auch
schon wirklich sehr sehr oft in der
werbung gesehen gab es auch in mengen
also und er scheint wirklich beliebt zu
sein erdbeerjoghurt machen wir mal auf
man sieht es wie von hand gemacht ja ich
glaube maschinen haben da wirklich gar
nichts mit der produktion zu tun da seht
ihr wirklich jedes stück eine komplett
gleich aus fliegt aber eigentlich echt
ganz lecker wie viel kalorien haben wir
wenn ich jetzt nicht dumm bin sind das
insgesamt 2.000 kalorien also komplett
die sechs stücke
ich hole mal kurz eine gabe hat benutze
ich eigentlich nie so hart habe ich den
irgendwie aus dem tiefkühlfach geholt
guten appetit und der kugelbahn seinen
tatsächlich in der tiefkühltruhe habe
ich gar nicht so wirklich nur die etwa
noch recht kalt ist auch nicht so
wirklich meins also keine ahnung da ist
ich liebe an erdbeerkuchen von meiner
mama oder so dass ich mich besser
schöne grüße
schafft ein atemberaubendes braten es
mit jeder haarwäsche und jeder sprühen
man farbintensität gewinnt und haus hat
das nicht gerade schön
das muss ich ja gut dass ich die kamera
jetzt gerade auf mich geschwenkt habe
weil das hätte ich alles zensieren
müssen
ich wusste gar nicht dass man nackte
menschen jetzt auch schon unter 22 ohne
werbung zeigen sie hatten zum schluss
haben wir noch das plant uhr 39 shampoo
ich wollte kurz noch duschen das
probiere ich mal aus sechs euro 95
familie werbung nicht gesagt nur ist es
halt wirklich nicht für mich bestimmt
für das h ab 40 also wenn es langsam
grau wird da bin ich ja noch weit
entfernt ich mein ich bin da gerade mal
17 aber das probieren wir mal aus ich
will noch mal sehen wie das aussieht
weil es war ja echt teuer dieses shampoo
sieht aus wie ja eigentlich ist das ja
schon oder ist einfach genau in der
farbe wie die verpackung
ich hab da mal etwas nass gemacht
vielleicht geht ihr soweit setzte
plötzlich raus den ich glaube
auf jeden fall wieder komplett frei also
wenn ihr über 40 seiten scheiße die
kameras gehören wenn ihr über 40 sein
wird das wirklich
das war's mit dem video das damals gut
wir sehen uns sonntag wieder das waren
man wirklich schöner abschluss